it's that time again
wedding season is underway and it is
extremely busy after
thousands of ceremonies were postponed
last year according to the website
the knot the number of couples ordering
save the dates more than tripled at the
start of this year compared to the fall
and couples are feeling more confident
about inviting in-person guests with
about
63 saying they'd have more than 100
people going to their weddings
but many questions still remain on how
to plan or attend a wedding during a
during the pandemic lauren k executive
editor of the knot
joins us now lauren i'm going to a
wedding later this month and i am so
excited we think i was getting married
but you know there are a little bit of
nerves just about doing this again for
the first time
for couples planning weddings now what
should they consider especially in terms
of size you know you want to have all
your friends and family but you also
want to be safe and not be responsible
for anyone possibly getting sick
absolutely so safety measures are still
top of mind for couples getting married
this whole new normal is a very fluid
ever changing situation so follow your
cdc guidelines
follow your local and state guidelines
and think about things you can do to
make your guests feel more comfortable
we found that when we surveyed guests
over 70 percent wanted to know the
safety precautions that couples were
taking
so put that information on your wedding
website let them know if you're wearing
masks if you're mandating vaccines
that will make everyone feel a little
safer when they're celebrating is it
okay to mandate
vaccines and if so what's the proper
etiquette you think just to kind of make
that ask a little smoother
so it is such a personal choice it
really depends on how you're getting
married where you're getting married
there's so many factors so the best
thing is for you to arrive at a decision
and then communicate it with your guests
we see as more and more vaccines are
becoming available more and more couples
expect that their guests will have an
opportunity to be vaccinated
and into the 2022 wedding season we're
expecting about one in three couples
will require vaccinations
so it's definitely happening but it's a
personal choice you have to make
lauren so many couples postponed
weddings over the past
year and a half so now there's like a
mad rush to the altar
is it possible to get a deal at this
point given that everybody is in
such high demand you know what i love
about this pandemic is it's required
everyone to get creative when it comes
to weddings so
you're right very few people actually
canceled most postponed and we're seeing
47
of weddings this year happening between
july and october so the competition is
real
so the cool thing though is people are
thinking outside the box they're having
ceremonies on different days of the week
they're hosting a brunch reception
they're thinking outside the box when it
comes to venues
and that's what's bringing a lot of the
originality of the couples into play
here and it makes it possible for
everyone to still get married you just
have to get a little creative hey lauren
as much as i love
a good wedding i think the couples are
probably looking forward to the
honeymoon a little bit more
than the gathering of all these people
and all these complicated etiquette
questions
so when it comes to honeymoons the
really fun part
where are people going and and what
should they be considering as they take
that jump so safety still top of mind a
lot of couples are putting that
big life-changing trip on hold because
borders and travel restrictions are
still in play
and they're taking what we're calling a
nano moon so they might be headed to a
vineyard a beach
a national park anything with outdoor
appeal is definitely trending right now
and they're taking a little weekend away
just to recharge and experience their
life as newlyweds and then they're
planning a much bigger trip when borders
and restrictions lift
later in the year or in next year lauren
let's talk about the thing you're not
supposed to talk about
money what do you suggest for people
who've been affected by the pandemic
people are hurting right now in their
wallets
what's appropriate for a gift so we
always say let your relationship
really determine how much you're going
to spend on a wedding gift always spend
with what in
your means you're comfortable with so if
it's a close friend or a family member
you might spend closer to the 100 to 200
range where if it's a co-worker or a
casual acquaintance you might be more in
that 50
range if you're in an urban city you
might spend a little bit more so it
really is dependent on what you're
comfortable with
and your relationship with a couple the
other thing to keep in mind is group
gifting
as you said a lot of people experience
financial hardships due to the pandemic
and a group gift is a great way to all
pull money together and get something
really fantastic from the couple's
wedding registry
if someone you know got mad quickly got
married during the pandemic in a small
ceremony
but you weren't invited should you still
send them a gift i say do
you celebrate these people they had to
plan postpone
plan again get them the wine glasses
they'll use those a lot
that is a good solution that's a great
idea lauren k it's been a pleasure
having you on thank you very much